You get skinny and then you want to cover it up.
I just wore clothing, baggy clothes, things that hid my body.
I would have little games in my head that I would play
like let's see how long I can go without eating.
I would definitely still be starving myself if I had not found circus artists.
I’m Kayla Dyches and I’m a professional aerialist
and a survivor of anorexia.
I did gymnastics and developed anorexia in my teens into my 20s.
At my lowest point I was 90 pounds,
and that's when I discovered circus arts.
It changed my life because I knew
that if I wanted to do it, I needed to grow stronger
and grow from it.
It took me 8 years to get from there to here.
Anorexia never really goes away,
you just learn how to shut it out.
When I look in the mirror now, I don't see the muscle mass. I feel small.
Almost immediately I’m thinking, “you know that's not true.”
“You can climb two hundred feet straight up.”
I had no idea from my first day that this would end up being my profession.
Back then, you know, I would cook
a pot of noodles
And I would have to get my then-husband
to strain the noodles for me because I didn't have the strength
to lift the pot of water and noodles and pour it out.
I remember asking, “what is wrong with me?”
And one of my trainers looked at me and she said, “You need to eat.”
I had fallen in love with aerial so much so that I was willing to put food in my mouth
and grow some muscle so I can get up in the air and keep up with all my classmates.
If I could say anything to my anorexic self,
it would be that “you could be so much nicer to your body.”
At the time, I thought I was taking care of it.
I wasn’t, and I didn't know any better.
I'm capable of so much more.